Ya tenemos las herramientas necesarias para factorizar este binomio
"x" cuadrada más 4x menos 5 y básicamente lo que hacemos es buscar,
2 números que cuando los multiplicamos nos quede -5 pero que cuando lo sumemos nos quede 4.
Entonces lo que hacemos es tomar este número y escribir todos sus factores,
en este caso estamos tratando con un número primo.
Entonces va a tener simplemente 2 factores los cuales son 1 y 5,
porque es un número primo y por aquí como tenemos aquí -5,
entonces sabemos que 1 de estos 2 números es negativo y el otro positivo,
entonces en realidad tenemos a la pareja de números
-1 y 5, esa es una de las parejas y la única otra pareja es 1 y -5
¿Ok? Pero, de hecho esta pareja es la que funciona,
por que -1 por 5 sí es -5 pero además -1 más 5
es 4 entonces, utilizando las herramientas que ya conocemos
esta expresión es igual a
"x" menos 1
por
"x" más 5, aunque sabes qué, déjame usar colores para que se vea más bonito y
porque puede ayudar a entender algunas cosas más adelante en este vídeo.
Entonces a este -1 lo vamos a pintar de rosa
y a este 5 lo vamos a pintar de azul y podemos aquí rápidamente
verificar que esta multiplicación de binomios si nos da esta expresión.
Tenemos aquí "x" por "x" nos da "x" cuadrada y después -"x".
Nos queda una -"x" pero luego por aquí tenemos más 5 por "x",
entonces tenemos más 5x menos 1x y entonces si nos queda 4x
y finalmente -1 por 5, -5.
Entonces estas dos expresiones si son iguales bueno pero, ahora lo que vamos a hacer es mucho más interesante.
¿Ok? Esto de aquí fue simplemente un repaso de algo que ya no sabemos perfectamente.
Ahora vamos a querer factorizar "x" cuadrada más
4xy menos 5y cuadrada y te recomiendo que le pongas pausa en este momento al vídeo,
y trates de resolverlo tú por tu cuenta, antes de que yo te dé aquí la solución.
El truco está en este término, aquí escribimos
4x por "y" y pues esa es la convención mundial del orden en el que se escriben las variables
pero pues, estamos haciendo una multiplicación entonces aplica la conmutatividad
y entonces este término es
igualito al término 4yx
este término es
exactamente igual a escribir "x" cuadrada más 4yx
menos 5y cuadrada.
Ahora esta es la forma en que se escriben los polinomios canónicamente
para que se vean más bonitos y todos entiendan mejor lo que estás diciendo
pero esta forma de escribir al mismo polinomio, en este caso, nos ayuda más,
porque si lo escribimos de esta forma
entonces podemos pensar a 4y
podemos pensar en este término como el coeficiente de esta "x", en esta ecuación sería
correspondiente a este coeficiente de esta variable "x" y de este lado
todo este término de aquí es equivalente a este término de aquí ¿Ok? Se ve muy
complicado ya con dos variables con una "y" aquí al cuadrado y todo
pero, en el fondo son exactamente la misma cosa y se resuelven de la misma manera.
¿Ok? Tenemos "x" cuadrada más un coeficiente por "x" más otro término que no depende de "x".
Entonces lo que vamos a hacer es buscar dos términos y en este caso van a ser
términos que contienen variables y no simplemente
números como estos números de aquí,
entonces buscamos dos términos que al
multiplicarnos nos de -5 por "y" cuadrada pero que a la hora de sumarnos nos de simplemente 4y.
Entonces pensemos en expresiones en términos que si los multiplicamos nos quedan -5y cuadrada.
Vamos a ponerle por aquí "y" por -5y,
si multiplicamos "y" por -5y nos queda -5y cuadrada muy bien.
Entonces ahora vamos a ver si lo sumamos nos queda 4y
-5y más "y" nos queda -4 y.
Bueno estuvimos muy cerca pero, necesitamos que sean más 4y en lugar de -4y
así es que vamos a ver si
funciona cambiar el signo de este término a este término.
¿Ok? Tenemos por aquí un menos entonces sabemos que va a haber un término que sí tenga signo menos,
y otro término que no tenga signo menos.
¿Ok? Entonces cambiamos el signo del lugar y nos queda -y y
5y a ver si funciona,
-y por 5y es -5y cuadrada muy bien, y por otro lado 5y
-y eso sí es 4y
y entonces esta pareja de expresiones es la que queremos.
Vamos a ponerle colorcitos  para que sea más fácil ver a dónde van a dar, y este 5y vamos a ponerlo de azul
¿Ok? Entonces ya tenemos 2 expresiones que si los multiplicamos nos da el término que no depende de "x"
y si las sumamos nos da el coeficiente de "x" así es que vamos a aplicar
exactamente la misma técnica que ya conocíamos para expresiones cuadráticas con una sola variable.
¿Ok? Vamos a poner por aquí
x menos y que es uno de los términos y eso tiene que ser multiplicado por "x"
más el otro término,
más 5y
¿Ok? Entonces yo afirmo que esta multiplicación de estos 2 binomios es exactamente igual a
este polinomio pero, pues todo lo que hacemos lo tenemos que verificar, así es que vamos a verificarlo,
Haciendo la multiplicación de estos dos binomios.
¿Ok? vamos a multiplicar este por este, y nos queda "x" cuadrada y ahora vamos a multiplicar
este por este y nos queda más 5y por "x", ahora multiplicamos
este por este nos queda -y por "x" y finalmente nada más nos falta multiplicar
este por este y nos queda -5y cuadrada,
y ya de aquí lo único que nos falta es agrupar los términos
para que veas que realmente es este mismo polinomio.
Entonces 5yx menos "y" por "x" pues aquí tenemos 5 de esta cosa, que es "y" por "x"
y le queremos restar 1 de esta cosa que es "y" por "x" entonces 5 menos 1 nos queda simplemente
4 de "y" por "x" pero "y" por "x" es exactamente lo mismo que "x" por "y"
entonces tenemos por aquí 4xy
y nada más tenemos que incluir al resto de los términos
y aquí tenemos a "x" cuadrada
y listo, este polinomio ya se ve muy claramente que es igual a este polinomio
pero pues, este polinomio es simplemente lo que nos queda de multiplicar estos dos binomios.